une aux stratégies de la langue de bois
c'est les statistiques j'sais pas si
vous connaissez peut-être la blague 98
perse 98 % des gens croient une statine
une information si elles contiennent
statistiques
en fait cette communication sur les
médias dominants sur france 2 ou autre
elle tourne en boucle sur trois
informations qui sont chaque jour de
nous annoncer un nombre de décès qui est
plus grand que la veille sans que ces
décès ne soit jamais rapporté à rien
c'est à dire que moi me dire il ya 400
morts ça peut être très effrayant que ça
peut l'être pas tellement si on met en
regard d'autres chiffres mais auquel
reconnaissez franck lepage qu'elle si au
moment où on apprend que plus de mille
personnes sont mortes dans les ehpad
depuis le début du confinement si on
disait bros et pas grand chose par
rapport aux 80 ou 100 mille morts
habituel chaque année ça choquerait tout
le monde vous compris et moi compris non
oui c'est juste que ces chiffres ne sont
pas éclairés et je peux rien faire avec
un chiffre pareil j'ai regardé les
chiffres en bretagne j'habite en
bretagne on est à 88 morts
bon la dernière fois que j'avais regardé
c'est la semaine dernière on était à 32
morts ok 32 morts de 32 à 88 c'est moche
c'est vraiment pas terrible
80 est mort il ya trois eu trois
millions et demi de personnes en
bretagne etc excusez moi mais enfin je
veux dire 88 morts sur trois millions et
demi de personnes
est ce que c'est un chiffre inquiétant
j'en sais rien je ne peux pas analysé ce
chiffre je ne comprends pas ces chiffres
donc sur cette question des chiffres et
les ailes et extrêmement perturbantes
parce que à la fois c'est une
information qui est angoissante ça qui a
une hystérisation du problème on nous
annonce des nombres de morts mais en
même temps si on met ces chiffres on
regarde d'autres chiffres ça devient ça
devient presque bizarre c'est ses 73
mille mans du tabac chaque année en
france
les morts dans les ehpad ses 400 par
jour normalement enfin vous savez on est
on nous a parlé de la grippe saisonnière
tout ça leur faisait toujours des gens
qui disent non non peut pas comparer on
peut toujours comparer l'intérêt de la
comparaison c'est précisément de mettre
des choses qui sont pas acquis sans
qu'ils sont pas les mêmes donc voilà
donc sur cette communication par les
chiffres
je sais pas quoi vous dire je suis
vraiment perplexe ce que j'ai décidé si
d'arrêter d'écouter les informations
parce que c'est terrible c'est
complètement angoissant
[Musique]